j'accepte jouèrent
ce que j'avais refusé avant
castelli venu voir lympia justement
alors il m'a dit que j'avais un rôle
dans cette pièce donc un jeu refusé de
le faire basculer chose une idée un
personnage si certaines carrières gîte
idée de soi même disons et j'étais un
peu enfermé dans un univers en moins
alors j'ai refusé de le faire il a fallu
qu'ils m'envoient à londres pour le voir
et qu'ensuite d'urss entre le même choc
en voyant les auditions à paris que le
choc que j'ai ressenti à londres en
voyant le show et là j'ai accepté de le
faire dans ma foi le bilan c'est le
coeur ça m'a apporté énormément parce
que ça m'a apporté du point de vue et
professionnels bon je n'avais jamais
joué la comédie de ma vie je chante des
chansons qui sont pas loin s'ils forment
ce cas totalement différente c'est à
dire que ça quand on l'a compris les
rouages de deux aires en tant que
spectacle mois qu'on a on peut avancer
beaucoup dans ton du spectacle ça ça
ouvre la voie à beaucoup de chose
d'autre une forme ce cap nouvelle et
puis du point de vue personnel aussi
vraisemblement ça va ça m'a ouvert
l'esprit sur d'autres choses que sur mon
monde à moi est à dire une certaine
vision de la vie et autres dix ans
ça m'a permis de me poser des problèmes
que je m'étais jamais posé problème
c'est normal l'artiste il ya une
solitude de l'artiste on travaille seul
là on travaille en groupe
rien que le fait de cette vie en tribu
au moins sur la scène
ça apporte énormément moi j'avais plus
vécue en groupe depuis éclaireurs de
france reste longtemps
revenons à la chanson pendant dix mois
julien vous avez une recette du succès
pour non non je travaille avec mes deux
paroliers ont fait des en fait des
chansons dont on a envie d'en faire ma
foi c'est tout je crois quand on n'a pas
envie d'en faire on en fait pas dans dix
ans vous avez de la chance il ya une
chanson j'aimerais bien qu'on écoute
cette situation ce qui revient c'est un
petit peu une chanson d'amour 20 et
plein d'espoir peu plus tendre un peu
plus tendue que d'habitude on va faire
un essai vers la tendresse
elle écoute
si tu reviens komm u9
n'oublie pas le pain
est épuisant au sourire
charmant qui m'a manqué
bon je sais le fin des allumettes le
quotidien et puis était
ont tué notre famille
on ne change pas
de change
ces corps
ton amour d'alors
comment
j'y vais
rendue dans un été trop têtu
quand
si tu
bien change pas ta tête ou l'art indien
des garettes ne fait pas le détour du
boucher je crois qu'il a été
payer ce prix soudain ma guitare sèche
que je chante depuis centriste est amour
màj frais
hudon année
/
bien
fait piquant
les clés sont chez le même
je crois qu'il s'en souvient
carla